So.
Yo, this guy went from it's really hard because I'm surrounded by these, um,
a lot of girls I've never been, uh, hello
game on.
Is that what you saw when he looked up? I'm like,
you expect me to read all that. <laugh> it could be either man.
You know how annoying some text conversations? Aren't with one girl. Yes.
40 of them.
This man's after. Good. So he is like, eh, you know, I'll be honest with you.
I'm not picky.
So I'll take whatever I can get. I like that. This guy. Good. Right attitude.
He's not like that. Yeah, girl. You know what I mean? He's I, I,
I have faith in this, man.
You do not know how to think selfies, bro. I don't think selfies,
but from the bottom bro, <laugh>
which your double <laugh>. He doesn't have a double chin.
He's just awkward about it. This is awkward. I can tell. You're not pick.
I don't think you have any right to be picked. That's what his looks at.
Whatever he is <laugh> that's what his PI looks at. He's like,
oh, is you again? Right? Cool. I thought was getting some actioning.
That's funny. This pee pee. All right, cool. Let's do this. Uh.
Huh. Uh, set.
It's like it goes exactly right to plan.
I just feel like playing the theme for casino, Roy. How? You know?
Cause this man is smooth ain, kitty.
Isn't it ironic that they love kids in a country where people aren't birthing
kids at all? Uh, is it Korea or China? It's Japan,
but Korea is not that far off.
Okay.
You have to understand that the,
the standards that they have of beauty are very white.
So they do like the eyelid thing. The eyelid, the that's not white. No.
That's that's been cleared up what? To have eyelids. Yeah. No.
That's that's been, have been in Korea forever. Forever. When is,
when is forever? Well, over 200 years.
It's part of their history. It's not about whiteness. Okay, cool. Yeah.
Well there's a con contact lens. That's been what their history is. You as well,
right? No, it's been white people. It's not white people, bro.
You look the contact contact lenses. No,
he's just saying that because if you have bad eyes, don't like,
I would rather you wear contact lenses and glasses,
but the whole ice thing that that's not whiteness. You make it up. Yeah.
Same thing with Japan. The enemy characters are not white. No,
I know they're not white.
Yeah. Well it's similar. I got educated on this cuz we mentioned this in a past.
Yeah.
And someone that hit me up and they're like actually should read up and I was
like, oh I was wrong. Cool. Yeah. Yeah.
But you're right about the beauty standards being different. For sure.
There's much more emphasis on eyes over there.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> but it's not necessarily cuz of whiteness all. Okay.
So yeah.
You were saying about their culture and the differences. It,
it is gonna be harder for us to check out, which is what what's gonna happen.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> and how they're gonna react because it's so different.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> so the culture is so different.
The beauty center is different. So yeah.
It's gonna be hard for me to even call this thing. That's fair. That's true.
But he is doing so well really well. So far I'm pretty impressed.
<laugh> this is the first time his face broke. So I might have up dang
circular glasses. Are that popular, right? No, that's interesting.
<laugh> this man knows his skillset. He's like, ah, you do do the work please.
I'm not gonna instigate. I'm not, I'm not like that. So that's interesting.
Are you active or passive at night? I mean, you know,
do you stay home or you just take walks <laugh> do you take up the whole bed or
do you just stay in your corner? That's what?
I would've assumed diagonally or like starfish
<laugh> that's everyone's confused. Okay. I'm glad.
Cause I'm like no cause though it's so yeah. Yeah.
He's trying to find a respectful way to be like you are freak. I like Korean.
I like language. Cause I used to watch a lot of K dramas every time I hear Jule.
Oh they always sound like they're complaining.
So it's my favorite language nowadays. Why could you like complaining? Yeah.
What our whole video is? What our whole channel is. It's a complaints channel.
It's not commentary. Yeah. It's complaints. I'm part Korean. You didn't.
I do Kpop fans. Let's go. And El also likes to go the leads <laugh>
are you passive? Are you active at night? <laugh> pinging.
Pinging. Ping. Ping beep.
Wow. He, oh
yo what's up Korea. Why?
I got so many passive women trying or maybe it's just disrespectful to ask that
in that context. Yeah. It could be a lot of things. Yeah. Yeah.
It could be like, why would you, you base yourself on that? It's like,
it depends of how they take it. Yeah. I agree with that. Maybe the girl,
some of the girls that exhibited oh, a big old freak.
But I also, if by the question, yeah,
or maybe like the national animal for Korea is the starfish. Yes.
That's how you know, these people are better than Jubilee's candidates.
Cuz these people have to go through eight questions to get through everybody.
Jubilee had four rounds and there was zero people left.
Maybe the people are more shallow. It depends of where like it.
It was.
I don't know me. I don't care how I thought the girl is. You know what I mean?
If, if you're small, small, I just pick you the up. And I,
and I hug you if you're tall.
I mean, yo, come here, you big tree girl.
And I just I've done that before on you and hug you. So it doesn't matter.
You don't think I want to get on my tippy toes. No, I'm ready to do that. Go.
Let's go. It don't matter if you seven, six, I don't care. Let's do this.
I've had experience. I've dated girls that were taller than me girls. Like,
are you okay with this? I was like, look at me. I'm the, the now.
<Laugh> no,
The
Do.
And.
It's crazy how his heart looks like it's breaking every time.
He really feels bad about hurting the crap. Yeah. Yeah.
It makes them more likable. Yeah.
You.
To.
To be honest, you want me to do it all?
Yeah. And this is why ladies,
you shouldn't put hype requirements in your profiles on tin.
If you felt bad during this whole process, stop this. But anyways,
I'm just joking. Y'all can do whatever y'all want. Um, it was interesting.
I thought it was way more. Why is it more?
Maybe it's also cuz it is a foreign culture. So it seems, yeah.
There's that there's that we, we, we, yeah, like I said,
we don't know what the outcome is gonna be. It's not that predictable to me.
The other thing I really liked about it was the compassion with which stated the
whole process. He seemed really concerned about the other people. Like to me,
I just like seeing that in any kind process. But I mean obviously they,
they look like they were compassionate at near the videos.
It's just that they did,
they showed it differently and it looked like it was fake because you,
maybe it was being fake. But I don't know. I can decide it. I mean,
I can only go for what, what if they're projecting?
You felt like they were being compassionate in the other videos. No,
I'm just saying they try to be, if you're a Virgo and she's like,
there was an arrogance to her requirements. That was one person. No.
So the ya yeah. True out the three videos we did on that. Yep. I know.
Maybe it's the place. Maybe I only, only go off what I see. Yeah.
Off other people.
All I'm trying to say is I enjoyed this one more because there seemed to be a
little bit more compassion it. Mm.
And there was a little bit more introspection with it. Mm.
And he came to a good conclusion. Mm. You know, it's like, it's like,
we covered that one dude with dig Jubilee. Yeah. He came out of he's like,
maybe some of my restrictions are too strict.
And he had like six girls at the end.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> whereas the girls were vapping at the end. Like, well,
I want one I want, and it's just like, Ugh. You know?
And it is nothing to do with gender. For me.
It's just like how you make your choices. Yeah.
I like this one because to me it seemed more insightful.
And also because it's a foreign culture, it's interesting to watch. Yeah.
It was good.
And they were also the first ones to do it and it definitely made it harder for
him just based off the questions he asked. So I did like that as well,
but I always that's it for today. If you guys like Korean culture,
maybe you'll check out that video. Otherwise it's just a cool video.
So go watch it.
So I know pizza loves Jubilee, right? Unfortunately,
the person that we're gonna be covering is the inspiration for Jubilee.
The people who Jubilee bit. Oh, they bit higher. Yeah.
They they've been biting content. Can we really call it biting?
If someone comes up with an original concept and you copy it. Exactly. Okay.
Yes. That's what it we're we're not talking about subjects. Hold on.
I'll show you I'll show you what I it's 40 versus one.
So basically he's surrounded by 40 goes.
That's biting a concept that is exactly the same concept.
And you're allowed to do that. It's okay. But I'm just saying it is what it is,
but anyways, let's, let's watch the Korean version and to be fair,
Korea comes up with some interesting concepts, whether it's ads,
whether it's videos or.